are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
that's stuff we have to talk about as
well episode 168 today folks with
adam saw snake uh did you see what i
just thought yeah it's pretty silly did
you see that
but my plan was to have it stand up
that's my standard but i
it dropped i saw it
so it's your version of the uh water
bottle flip right no it didn't work out
okay vino shana tom ellsworth 168.
lots to cover with you hope you had a
good fourth uh i know yesterday shout
out to mario mario
brought
i don't even know where he got this from
you know because you know in the
community when an iranian moves in
and fourth of july shows up neighbors
worry a little bit
because they don't know what kind of
fireworks you're gonna do so when an
iranian comes up and says i got some
fireworks i'm gonna do this weekend
everybody leaves the community that's
right they just say this is probably not
a good idea but last night what mario
did
was did you see that stuff like i don't
know if you signed it yeah
including the one where the box fell
over and it blew and it almost hit mario
oh really so so chicken did one of them
it just blew up right there bam
everybody but anyways hope you guys had
a good fourth of july no uh jason
pierre-paul incidents
yeah no jason people how was new york
you were in new york i freaking love new
york yeah tell us about it tell us about
it i mean i was just there for three
days filming a bunch of content um
how expensive is it to live in new york
are you considering leaving new york uh
21 billion dollars worth of wealth has
left new york yeah explain why you think
that is got all sorts of different
answers along with the taxes that's true
and
um the food then
the food was great little italy uh you
know chinatown uh katz's deli you gotta
go check out cat's deli get a pastrami
reuben sandwich just
i got i used to go to new york every
summer every summer for the last decade
and i haven't been since the lovely uh
uh trip to addison in dallas and i
haven't been back
exactly they don't it's not so it was
good to be back was you know i
i've asked a million people seeing this
you've seen this i said before the
pandemic if new york was a 10 right
vibrant hustling bustling everything
going on and then during the pandemic
everything shut down and went to a zero
where is it now
and i've gotten all sorts of answers six
seven four three two eight you know
i would say it's it's a solid eight
right now from the weekend like it's
good things are happening and things are
going on obviously during the summer a
lot of people go to the hamptons
especially on the weekend
but i i got a lot of good answers about
from new yorkers like anything that
stood out give us anything that stood
out
um
what stood out i mean
normalcy i think that's that's like all
right new york's back to normal again
there's there's still people running
around with mass on outdoors
they're responsible people they're very
you know outdoors that's kind of i get
it inside you don't want to you know
whatever
uh one bar i've been went to a bunch of
bars bunch of restaurants one bar at one
bar asked for a vaccine card before i
walked really yeah and i gave him like
my target card i was like he's like i
don't think they even looked
they're not i think they're just looking
for anything
um so you had a good time i had a great
time in new york well sounds good let's
talk about it i will say that there's a
there's a ton like i'm i'm waiting for
like some kind of there's no there's a
very overt out there like pride
situation going on cool i'm all for gay
pride great you know but like
very overt
very over were they convincing when they
spoke to you or no i was focusing on the
ladies i was like i kissed two guys
whatever you had to get in the club
somehow yeah but it was it was
you know
very overt so i feel like that pride
story there's a story there maybe you
don't want to we'll talk about we'll
talk about it no there's nothing going
on behind the scenes i swear i swear so
okay all right so aside from that story
that we have here folks a couple things
that's going on that i want to talk
about one
uh you always know when the market
correction is coming when first
luxuries start taking a hit exotic cars
watches rolex restaurants like exotic
exile like expensive places there's an
article we'll cover with that uh tyler
you may want to look that up the other
one is
companies are actually starting to
rescind offers like hey here's a job
offer 120 a year with a 20 000 bonus
with benefits and all this other stuff
you start the 17th awesome let me put a
two week notice and a week later listen
we're going to have to resend that job
offer we gave to you we're going a
different direction wow many many
companies are doing that today
zuckerberg called that many of his
employees prepared that article as well
with what zuckerberg said he says many
of you guys probably don't deserve to
work here and you're probably not good
enough to work here did you hear that
part with zuck so let's very offensive
but let's put that up there to talk
about that s p 500 falls uh to start to
start the month after a brutal first
half of the year
white house sparks backlash after saying
high gas prices guard
liberal world order maybe adam's got
some thoughts on that california to get
up to 2050 inflation relief through
newsome's budget deal fyi do not be
surprised it looks like tom has some
comments on this it looks like newsome
may be uh being put together to be the
2024
uh democratic nominee you said you said
that
a couple months ago we talked about that
but he he may be poisoned like he's
looking like he's going to be their guy
and replacing
biden peter schiff what's the story
petersham trying to say puerto rico
bank under probe okay we'll cover that
story july first that's right that's one
i sent you we'll cover that as well
quarter americans saying they are ready
to take up uh arms against the
government paul also finds the more than
a third of those currently owned guns
joe rogan claims desantis will be a good
president uh refers to biden as dead man
as president uh guatemalan president
kamala harris is missing an action
migration crisis we need greater
communication
uh percentage of americans saying the
country's head in the wrong direction
spikes to 85
we got a few other stories we'll get
into as well kevin durant requesting a
trade from the nets very surprised
because what this guy is famous for
knowing to do is he'll stay with the
team until they win a championship he
never takes the easy way out i'm
surprised he's doing this it's the first
time he's making a decision like that
logan paul future president
signs a wwe
contract and then rachel maddow is being
replaced with previously canceled alex
wagner
puzzles insiders no institutional memory
uh and then military branches are having
a hard time with their recruiting goals
so why don't we get right into tom with
the market here so s p 500
fails after a uh to have a good start
after a miserable
first half stocks fell friday after the
s p 500 closed its worst first half
performance in decades as disappointing
economic data continued to dampen market
uh sentiment several profit warnings
also pressured stocks the smp 500 dipped
0.2 dow jones industrial lost 105.3
percent nasdaq lost 0.2 percent all of
major averages were on pace for their
fourth down week in five the moves after
several companies lowered their profit
guidance adding to investor concerns
that persistent inflation had decades
long highs could continue to put
pressure on share prices consensus
estimates for 2022-2023 remains largely
unchanged from the start of the year
even though stock prices have declined
considerably since then weak guidance
could finally force cut to consensus
earnings estimates which would likely
add further downward pressure on stock
says greg marcus managing director of up
ubs
private wealth management tom what is
really going on with the market right
now well what's really going on is from
the white house to the treasury to the
lead analyst on wall street nobody wants
to walk across the line and say it's
really happening and it's really here
consensus estimates from the beginning
of the year are unchanged pat you just
read it yet
all the market indicators we can look at
every day from stock prices commodities
everything else is down
why are they not revising it because no
one wants to walk across the line to be
the first guy to say officially we are
in a deep bear market not just a bear
correction but a deep bear market number
one and number two the white house even
though we are officially as of july 1st
statistically in a recession nobody
wants to make that the lead stories and
so the white house and treasury have
friends on wall street and they don't
want with midterms and everything coming
up they don't want people to feed into
the recession a bull market story and so
that's why these analysts are sitting
there and sitting on the news when
reality we're in a bear market we're in
a recession but they're all afraid to be
the first credible voice to come across
the line and say man it's real and it's
here because guess what happens
someone has to do something about it and
that is the white house and raising
interest rates is the tool and nobody
wants that so everyone is scared to fall
across this this is unsurprising to me
but it underlines just how bad the
situation is for the economy so so you
know how uh uh you know how adam do you
have any comments on that on what uh
yeah well look uh i just came back from
new york i definitely
went to wall street i mean it was in the
weekend so you didn't really see
you know the nysc and everything that's
going on during the week during the
hoopla but i walked by the raging bull
right you know the uh the bull the bull
of wall street and the defiant little
girl
the fire girl saw her too
um and it and i
and i remember a quote that i heard
about markets and tom you might want to
weigh in this and it says that um
bull markets will make you money
but bear markets can make you rich
so if we are entering a bear market
or if we're already there okay let's use
that
to our advantage right so when
everything's going up and up and up all
right everyone's making money but if you
position yourself correctly
and you understand what's coming and and
you are prepared then you have the
opportunity to make a lot of money pat
you went off on you're a lot about to
see a lot of people worth a hundred
grand be worth a million you're allowed
to see someone who's worth a million add
another zero 10 million if you're worth
10 minutes like this is the time if you
prepare yourself
uh proper preparation prevents poor
performance right that was what i always
say yep and um
warren buffett was just quoted by elon
musk his strategy the ppp strategy which
is predict
prepare
and persevere there we go and shout out
to valuetainment.com for writing that
article so here's my question guys so
like somebody like me that
doesn't really know about stocks and but
whatever you guys i mean i'm trying to
soak it in but what do you tell the
average person that's not involved and
you know doesn't know about what you're
talking about getting it they're [ __ ]
struggling right now yeah [ __ ] is bad
and like what do we just tell them hey
listen that's that the white house is
basically just saying hey suck it up
they even said this it's a new liberal
world order suck all this [ __ ] up gas
prices everything we're going somewhere
else like the whole going green [ __ ]
they took out all the white ones binding
got it no drilling no oil no nothing
it's like hey deal with it because
you're trying you're asking what the
regular guy what's a regular guy number
one pat and number two do you think if
trump i'm going right back to politics
if trump was in because my cousin was
like what would have trump done
different what do you think if trump was
in power i want to ask all you guys what
would it still be happening right now
what's happening right now first of all
first of all did you guys see
uh griner open letter did you guys know
grinder open letter yesterday do you
know who i'm talking about on a britney
can you pull this up brittany griner
writes an open letter to who
joe biden you guys realize she's been
out there months four months okay so
brittany if you're listening to this in
russia and you want to know who to
really write the open letter to write it
to trump he'll probably get you out yup
can you imagine she says i'm terrified i
might be here forever and biden what has
he done what has kamala done i'm sorry
kamala aren't you supposed to be a gamer
here aren't you supposed to get up there
and make a video and say something about
to get her out how was she stuck there
this entire time do you guys remember
when jorge ramos who hates trump
do you remember where jorge ramos was
stuck where was ramos stuck do you guys
remember when ramos had an issue you
guys don't remember this no tyler do you
remember this with ramon you're talking
about university owned ramos jorge ramos
where was he is cuba he was he was stuck
i'll tell you right now i'll pull it up
right now exactly what it was sick right
he got sick and then he had so he had
something going on
that he comes out and then trump trump
comes out of nowhere and defends this
guy
so you got a grinder here who is asking
hey that's it venezuelan government
detained him and him and trump has all
the people oh he can't stand hey trump
hates him who bails them out trump and
guess who he thinks
trump he thanks trump
shout out to him so
grinder if you're listening to this i
can't stand the fact that you're stuck
there i can't stand the fact that you're
stuck there the current administration's
campaign was to protect people like
yourself okay you were the person they
were supposed to protect and go after to
make sure nobody messes with you you're
stuck in russia biden hasn't made one
phone call to say you better release
them or else i'm going to put more funds
and strength in ukraine there is zero
help going on here okay zero so here's
the thing which the comment you just
made yesterday a guy says to me i post a
comment about uh the the tweet about i
don't know if you saw the tweet i i
tweeted about gas prices when uh uh
biden's tweet can you go to my twitter
account i'll just read you what i said
when he
says yeah when he says so one guy
commented i won't tell you what this guy
commented keep going up keep going up
keep going up uh up up up it's the one
when i respond to biden's tweet uh keep
going keep going keep going keep going
right there okay click on that one right
there
uh you can't do it can you okay all
right anyway so i respond to his tweet
biden says something about in a very uh
uh demanding voice which by the way i
don't understand why you read write it
like that
in a demanding voice he says
did you pull it up or it's not letting
you okay i'll just read it to you here
buddy it's okay we don't have to stress
out about it my message to the company
is running gas stations you ready and
setting prices at the pump is simple
this is a time of war in global peril
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you're
paying for the product and do it now
okay and this is my response mother
bezos responded first and he gave an
epic message this is the guy he
supported correct and now he's having
virus remorse okay the white house needs
to knock this off so i say i tweet this
out and i say first you blame trump
then covet then putin then oil companies
now gas station owners what's next
blaming car owners for driving too much
then a guy responds back on instagram
and he says the following it's very
important for you to see how the market
is responding to this kind of stuff and
i want to read this guy's comment and
i'll pose my question that i gave to him
he says patrick
we know it's the oil companies raking in
record profit
uh profits and the government collects
their share through taxes and political
contribution they all in on it what say
you patrick with david i don't know if
you speak like that but what say you
patrick david sometimes i talk like that
here's what i said
why were they not taking record profits
under trump
but they are underbide
why not
forget politics for a second and
actually answer that question and i got
a few more for you afterwards
if they're taking record profits now
and trump is pro oil
shouldn't they have taken record profits
under trump so where does that argument
go now
so wait a minute do you understand what
i'm saying here so hey if these oil
people are getting rich why do they get
rich under a biden administration not
under a trump administration world star
post something the other day about
about and by the way world start
if you were to guess which side
politically world star's audience falls
as a left middle or right
libertarian
world star no i would say they're
middlebury
they're left yeah they're 100 left
because a bunch of their videos that
they are left and this guy's actually
no he's joking right now it's left watch
this
go to the instagram post they put when
biden says
uh i'm tyler we can hear you type i'm
proud to say that america is officially
the first country in the world
to prove vaccines for six-month-old
babies here's what i want you to do
go read the response of people on that
post
you know what you realize
more people agree and are on the same
page than you think
set aside identity politics left right
middle center whatever [ __ ]
95 of us all agree
on half the [ __ ] that's not working out
that's the problem today people are
sitting there saying the hell is this
guy saying i voted for this guy but what
are you talk what are you putting out
there man this is embarrassing take this
thing off don't don't put that up there
but you think they're staying quiet
because they're so loyal and they're not
going to [ __ ] admit that they're
messing up they're not are you sure no
no you don't need everybody to be
allowed you only need 10 of them to not
be happy and 10 of them are not staying
quiet they're sick of it they're done
with it they're like this is purely
games i'm freaking sick of it when you
mess with someone's kids and their
pockets they get upset and that's what's
happening today what's what's happening
today i'm by the way because uh trump
helped asap rocky when he was arrested
in what sweden remember that too he's
coming to the call because he doesn't he
doesn't mess around i was on a flight
the other day with kodak black oh yeah
really like is this kodak black i'm like
yeah it's kodak black he's sitting right
in front of me
and um
just a chill regular guy and i made the
mistake of kodak blue oh remember that
you're like no no it's code on the
podcast not to his face
mr blue it's so great to see yeah
so that that when you when you think
about what's going on with the economy
and the numbers by the way i want to
show you guys something with the economy
so do you guys know this uh this guy
named dave ramsey mm-hmm have you heard
of dave ramsey absolutely i heard that
guy's name
personal financial planning yes we'd
love to have him on the podcast but dave
ramsey i think you are wrong and let me
tell you why
so dave ramsey
is saying he doesn't think real estate
is going to take a hit
he thinks real estate is going to be
maybe a minor little hit but not a big
hit which by the way he may be right
however
there's one data point you have to look
at whether real estate's going to take a
hit or not because that's where his
argument is his argument is how is real
estate gonna take a hit
if inventory isn't there well
if inventory isn't there guess who's
right
dave ramsey is right
why here's why because say i'm a realtor
and adam is looking to buy a million
dollar house okay and he specifically
wants to buy this house in a community
that is close to the school because he
wants his cats and his kids to go to a
nice private school but the challenge is
the best there is only one there's only
two million dollar homes in the market
one of them doesn't have a swimming pool
the other does have a swimming pool he
wants a swimming pool one is four
bedroom the other one is three bedroom
he needs four bedrooms so i go there and
i say adam i don't think we're gonna
make a million dollar offer here because
you're not gonna get it he says what do
you mean i said if you try to negotiate
hard here you're gonna lose because
they're gonna get 50 offers i say we go
strong what are you talking about i say
we go with an offer of 1.15 pat it's a
million dollar listing i say you offer
1.1 1.15 if you really want this thing
because if you don't it's going to go
cash cash is going to come in 1.2 so
adam's now panicking and by the way my
argument as a realtor in that situation
guess who's right i'm right in that
situation and adam sits there and says
what damn this guy's right why because
he goes on realtor every day and nothing
new is popping up yes or no when you're
looking at houses right so adam says
okay pat i'm not going to make an offer
1.15 but i'll make an offer for what a
million 85 okay great he puts the alpha
4 million 85 we send it in their realtor
comes back saying we got 47 offers the
biggest one is 1.11 this is your last
chance what do you want to do i tell
adam adam if you don't get this there's
probably not going to be anything for
another year or two adam comes back and
says let's make that offer 1.16 he loses
that 1.17 okay wow today if inventory
was 50 for the million dollar house and
30 of them had a swimming pool with four
bedroom guess what adam's now doing
adam's saying make an offer of 880. yeah
making off for a ninth i'm not making a
million dollar offer there's 45 other
properties i can look at
so here's
what dave ramsey says
the housing market is not crashing sorry
to end your fear porn party but the sky
is really not falling it's definitely
scary and some of the things going on
truly do suck but the sky is not falling
and the way he's explaining it is the
fact that the inventory
is not there now pull up the data i just
pulled uh sent to you from realtor.com
this is realtor.com article okay and it
shows what's happened go up a little bit
and then zoom in go up go up go up go up
to the chart and then zoom in zoom in
okay check this out guys look at this go
a little bit out okay there you go watch
this
so active listing count the years you
see the colors 2017 18 19 20 21 22 22 is
at the bottom it's the yellow one do you
see that okay so
inventory active listing in january to
february it goes down
february to march pretty even
march to april about flat april to may
boom
may to june
boom
18.7 year-over-year
this data increasing is the scariest
thing for realtors and it's the best
thing for buyers so if this thing climbs
up dave ramsey has to apologize to his
fan base for getting this wrong and it's
going up if this thing goes down we will
give dave ramsey a shout out for getting
it right but it's that simple
folks if there's any data you want to
watch pay very very close attention to
this you know how you were going to
shops and you didn't see any rolexes for
sale
plenty of rolex's for sale right now
right now everybody's telling them they
want to buy rolex they're everywhere
right and why why they go on ebay
they're everywhere they're selling
everything people are getting rid of
everything i mean listen wall street
journal story came up
pull up the wall street journal story
about uh uh anyways tom i'll turn it
over to you give some thoughts on this
on what i'm saying yeah there are three
things that are out there driving this
right now that are all facts and by the
way i love it when you put the charts up
there because whenever i go toe-to-toe
with liberals i have a little phrase i
like uh-oh facts here they come well the
first thing you've done is the inventory
so what's making the inventory dave
ramsey is not liberal whatsoever just so
you talk about dave okay about the facts
here gotcha so the first element is that
right now
those people that partnered maybe you
and me adam we partnered we were trying
to do a couple house flips here in south
south florida guess what the party's
over what are we saying to each other
right now hey we don't have deep pockets
we're not like blackrock buying up
residential real estate everywhere guess
what we need to get out of this now
these the prices are flattening out
interest rates are going up we have to
get out we're putting inventory on
that's first second there is
unemployment that is starting to happen
in key areas that inventory is coming on
market and third the as soon as the
price is level all of the sidelines this
is the biggest group pat people that
were on the sidelines that was thinking
of selling a house maybe moving or
retiring going a different area they've
been watching the prices go up and
remember when prices go up like stock
goes up i won't sell it today maybe
apple will be 1700 tomorrow i won't sell
at 1700 maybe apple will be 1800
tomorrow you know you get talked into
the next level agree you know what i
mean pat the next one percent those
people that are on the sideline are
bringing inventory on the market right
now because they say the party's over
and i'm getting out all of that is
driving inventory and by the way
the normal number one thing that drives
inventory is job change it's forced
inventory and that that storm hasn't
even come ashore yet but if you want to
do the real estate market like a
hurricane map here in florida it's
coming all of this is driving inventory
and it it has to drive prices down so
ramsay and other people that are maybe
living in denial and thinking it's not
going to happen not going to be so bad
it's going to bottom out right here no
it's not we got another three quarters
interest rate two weeks ago right here
come let's see interest rates and the
layoffs are gonna keep feeling it
talking fast so i can get it done
there's there's two camps here
choose your camp
choose your camp folks there's the one
camp
that's saying
nothing's wrong everything's going to be
all right
the house prices are not going to drop
don't worry about it keep spending your
money keep living your website the same
exact way that's one camp the other camp
is
shit's about to hit the fan
real estate's going to drop inflation's
going to keep going up interest rates
are going to go up the next 12 18 24
months are going to be ugly but it's
going to be fine it's not the end of the
world will come out of this in the next
two three four five years and then
everybody goes back to business as usual
here's the key about these two different
camps whichever camp you choose you just
hope you're part of the right camp in
two years okay because if you're part of
the wrong camp in two years you are not
gonna come out of this thing better than
you were prior to this camp so to the
dave ramsey camp look go to the other
part about the savings these are a
couple things folks have to pay close
attention to uh this is a wsj story
americans tap pandemic savings to cope
with inflation okay what happens when
people start tapping into their savings
because inflation they run out of
savings and then after they run out of
savings what do they do they start
selling things that they have and when
they start selling things that they have
what happens when a seller is selling
something and he has to use that thing
that he's selling to pay the mortgage
next friday uh and you tell him i'll
wait two weeks and he says no no no but
what if we do a deal right now no no no
i'll buy it in two weeks no no right now
you can screw them listen not screw them
it's not screw them it's called being
irresponsible
i've been irresponsible when i was
forced to sell stuff because i
desperately needed money and a person
that was responsible guess what that
credit goes to the person that was
responsible there's nothing wrong with
the guys that hey when everybody else
was partying you were saving money then
when the time comes like this this is
the time when you get to buy things for
sale while everybody else was buying 700
bottles and you were not
that's just there's that's that's all
there is to it works in your 20s 30s 40s
when that age starts with four man that
stuff kind of changes a little bit but
anyway so yeah interest rates the other
thing i want you to pull up if you could
do me a favor uh tyler pull up go to
google and type in history of u.s
interest rates
history of u.s interest rates watch this
one here which is freaking very
very interesting history of usn let me
see not that one there's there's one
that i want you to pull up
which is which is the main one to pull
up it's the one i used yesterday
uh
history of interest rates from 1970 to
today that's right this is where jimmy
carter looks at the car and goes hey
look i won uh no jimmy actually you did
yeah you're losing money when you when
you look at this interest rates it shows
5.7 today
and then when you go back on what the
rates were like let me see if i have the
article here because this is the one
that folks if you see this article
a look at historical markets forbes
advisor let me pull this one up forbes
uh advisor i'll send this to you and
da da da da da i don't know what's wrong
with somebody
uh
keep going up keep going up okay right
there zoom in that's the one that's
exactly the one okay so zoom in all the
way into today
zoom in zoom in zoom in zoom and zoom in
until it's so close keep going zoom and
zoom and zoom and zoom and zoom in
that's the most you can go okay so how
scary does that look not that bad
right if you look at that what does that
story say you're like pat i mean listen
man what are you guys panicking it's
only five point seven percent
okay i mean if you go a little bit back
keep going all the way like put your uh
put the thing on it no put the mouse on
the yeah keep going back once the last
time it was five point seven keep going
back back back back two thousand nine
eight coming down
right there when is that 2008 coming
down okay so 2005.7 all right now in
2007 when it was 5.7
had we printed the amount of trillions
of dollars that we printed now no no we
keep going back we were printing houses
six percent keep going back keep going
back seven percent keep going back seven
percent eight percent keep going back
nine percent keep going back keep going
back keep going back keep now zoom in a
little bit so everybody sees what
happens here okay now go all the way to
the top and what is that 18.37
and what jimmy carter did is not 1 100
at what we're doing right now with the
way we're printing money
so that right there folks if you're
listening
that's the worst case scenario the worst
case scenario is 18.37 which i don't
think we're going to get to the worst
case scenario but the best case scenario
is somewhere in the middle that we can
potentially get to that 5.7 could hit
10.
just telling you it could don't be
surprised if it goes to eight to ten
percent maybe higher than that for like
a month or two and then all of a sudden
they start printing three trillion
dollars of money again to solve it and
it could get nasty so dave ramsey may be
right but there's this thing called data
and it looks like inventory is going up
and history of rates 5.7 right now is
still cheap and we're probably going to
hit 7 8 9 10 sometime in the next six 12
24 months you know what's interesting um
i'd like to find out what they did what
the fed did what the presidency did
during carter during the late 80s when
reagan came in and early 80s uh what
they did to fight inflation like that
what what did they do to fight these
interest rates meaning like
right now you talk about quantitative
easing they've done all that now they're
raised raising uh interest rates uh by a
court uh three quarters of a percentage
what did they do then and how long did
it take to
settle down the economy this is before
my time you were probably in your late
teens 20s during at this time so maybe
you remember what they did economically
do you remember what they did yeah i did
my dad my dad had conversations with me
about it and um there's two things and
he used to say he didn't talk about
capitalism but he said listen reagan is
going to expand the economy and when the
economy expands taxes are created and
they naturally
you know cure a lot of ills they build
jobs so the government doesn't have to
provide assistance they create expansion
and taxes for the government so the
government doesn't have to raise taxes
and reagan came in and made a reagan tax
cut
and also
uh drove expansionist policies because
he had to do he had to whip two things
at the same time it was um jimmy carter
and this is one of the great moments in
presidential debates um jimmy carter had
assailed gerald ford in 1976 that
election saying
you know mr ford you know you um there's
a misery index on the american people
you know it's five percent interest
rates and it's six percent unemployment
that's a misery index of 11 or 12
whatever it was four years later
reagan looked at him at the presidential
debate said mr carter i'd like to remind
you you invented the misery index
and then then it was up to 21. so he
says congratulations you've increased
the misery index which you defined but
it was
reducing
regulation of businesses expansionist
economic policy and he cut taxes and
guess what happened people got jobs
people paid reasonable taxes with those
jobs the economy expanded and you can
take a look it went down as fast as it
went up
and you know back then there's a guy
named david stockman the liberals used
to refer to it as
voodoo economics trickle-down theory but
guess what
history shows it worked do you remember
what made voodoo economics famous
in ferris bueller's day off when he's
like uh
uh
right it was it was very simple we want
to reduce taxes let the economy expand
get people get jobs and the people to
new jobs pay reasonable taxes and the
whole thing will work one of the things
you always hear about reagan was
trickle-down economics trickle-down
economics doesn't work i mean i don't
have a like a horse in this race on
trickle-down trickle-down economics but
that was sort of
reagan's thing what are your thoughts on
that i i i think just let's go back and
take a look at the expansion of gdp the
expansion number of jobs and
unemployment went down
so when people can get a house at a more
reasonable interest rate they're happy
when they have a job they're happy when
they don't pay as much taxes on that
paycheck for that job they're happy it
seemed to be
that it worked pretty well for the
economy you go back look at historians
will say well reagan didn't do this
didn't do that look you can pick on any
president in a number of ways and reagan
had assumed
but
he turned this ship around by the way so
so think about it this way adam just
think about
you sell uh life settlement right and
you've sold other products
the way a comp structure is set up
produces the right behavior right so
okay so what behavior do we want right
now let's just say we're the
administration you're the president i'm
one of your strategists and we're
sitting here strategizing on how to
fix this economy right now
whose help do we need the most president
just fell asleep whose help do we need
right now whose help do we need if
you're the president we're the
strategist the economy is like this
right now whose help do we need
who's help doing help do you need well
clearly first and foremost the fed right
you need no
no he's can do [ __ ] i mean he's just
going to interest rate that's fake right
actual economy whose help do we need to
actually improve the economy uh business
owners okay so hiring okay perfect
employment so right now business owners
are firing
okay that's what they're doing they're
downsizing and it's not just one of them
many of them are right
so if you know that's what they're going
through
why do you think business owners are
firing
they're anticipating a recession of some
capacity and they're feeling what's
going on with their businesses right
okay so for example i'm talking to this
guy that's a
a mortgage guy loan officer out of a
hundred loan officers out there okay
when they did loans
did most loan officers what percentage
of the loans they did that they made
money on was a refi what percentage of
the loans that they did the last two
three four five years was a new purchase
for the last two three four years when
the interest rate's going down i'm
guessing 80 75 percent refund refi
okay so guess what that business is gone
yeah 100 which means you went from
making a hundred grand a month to making
25 grand a month
75 you understand what i just did right
okay sounds good so sure but but let's
go with me here so if you want business
owners if you need business owners what
can you do for the business owners to
not fire these employees what can you do
with them for the next two years
what can you do with the business with
the business owners that are about to
fire right now you're like okay guys
hold off what can you do to get business
owners the next two years to not fire
those people tax incentives tax
incentives for the next two years
tax incentives for the next two years
remember like
you know the structure's a plus minus if
in the next such and such time frame you
hire five more people we're gonna give
you the five more people you hire out of
fifty percent of the whatever salary we
give them we'll give you that as a tax
incentive so if i'm gonna hire five
people and each of them gonna be 50
grand that's what 250 if you said 50
incentive of taxes for the next two
years 125 now i'm hiring those five
people because we're sharing that
together so the business owner now sees
you as trying to work with them and a
business owner now has an incentive to
not fire those people but the way you're
doing it right now the business owner is
cornered to say what do you want me to
do yeah i have to make the tough choice
so that's well within the business
owner's rates and by the way of course
so who wins there think about who wins
there nobody
in that situation if if we keep those
five people and we don't fire them who
wins
well the employees who else wins
the business hopefully who else wins
the tax pool who else wins everybody the
president wins right the states won
because even you now don't have the
havoc of everyday people turning on
seeing this data
so that kind of a decision-making
process gets people to say
listen we're giving the business owners
more tax incentives do we want to do
that yeah but these guys are keeping
these people as a job that's a good
point and if these people are getting
jobs we don't have crime going up
because if people don't make money they
steal
and they're doing more dumb things of
taking out guns and desperation and
theft
you know what if we do this this could
actually bring crime down and maybe we
see fewer these horror stories we hear
yeah let's kind of work with the small
business owners because we need them
okay that's how you like when they did
the ppp loan that was just handing out
money i don't agree with the ppp it was
a mess it was a mess no this is about
hey no you're willing to do this i
wanted to give you that when you just
said ppp that's exactly what i was
thinking about what happened over the
past few years where they're just
incentivizing people to keep that state
you have to remember one thing about the
payroll incentives remember the tax
incentives is the federal government say
us us we the people helping the
individual states individual basis you
know why the first dollar welfare is at
the state level the first dollar welfare
your unemployment benefits are usually
at the state level
well
that means edd in california that is
where the unemployment benefits in the
state of california are coming from
which edd standpoint uh economic
development department okay or whatever
in sacramento edd and so when you have a
business in california you send your
state taxes to edd
so if the federal government says hey
hire those five people and i'm gonna
cover 125 tax incentives the federal
government does that that actually helps
california and it helps individual
states so we the people help the
individual states because the first
dollar welfare is usually at the state
level so that's example of our federal
government helping our state government
and the great handshake as it's called
working
and i i think the people like the
average person like me would ri i would
rather i mean it's never gonna happen
they would love to have uh an
administration that's going hey guys
we're [ __ ] up
buckle down it's happening right now
instead of just going like this
statement right here bring down the
pressure
let me tell you something i don't care
you you keep reverting back to well
would trump do something different with
biden with obama it's like who gives a
[ __ ] handle your own [ __ ] i'm not saying
you
yeah there's something called personal
responsibility there's something called
personal finance if you're always
looking at the president or the fed to
or the government
to bail you out or be your answer you're
looking in the wrong place you need to
look in the mirror so what like ask pat
i guarantee you pat made money under
obama i guarantee you've made money
under trump and i guarantee he's making
money under biden
now there are different tax strategies
he needs to you know encounter of course
are there different ramifications for
decisions he makes but at the end of the
day if you're a business owner or you're
an entrepreneur you got to figure it out
yourself
that's my thought
there's a part of that that's factual
and then there's the other part that you
have to pay more attention to who you
elect you just have to correct
you're right there's a part of it that
you're likely you can work for a company
and be like who cares who the ceo at the
top is
just go sell your policies who cares who
the ceo is
you're right but at the same time
if the ceo at the top is the right ceo
he'll be driving better he'll be setting
the example better he'll be coming up
with better innovative campaigns he'll
be thinking about how to make the
company better
that part is also it takes two to make a
thing go right it takes two one it takes
two us together we take over the world i
think there's a part of where both of
you are right and there's some
responsibility in these policies when
you're looking at this i'm looking can
you pull up the cnbc article about
what's going on with people have been
paycheck to paycheck this is i'm in the
58 percent yeah
i'm in the 58 everybody
of americans are living paycheck to
paycheck after inflation spike but this
is the most interesting data
including 30 of those earning 250 or
higher why do you think that well how is
that because of their what are you like
30 earning 250 or higher today
all the [ __ ] that they bought all the
stuff that they're paying yeah man
that's exactly right because america has
classically been an aspirational there
are three levels of luxury europe
purchasers pure cash
any economy any day he's got money next
one is pure cash good economy the next
level is aspirationalists who are
usually paying for them
on payments so you get a lot of good
realtors down in miami having heyday
1800 a month on
a bentley okay
guess what that has to go away they
didn't buy that car that car bought them
yep exactly and so that's
th this is exactly what i'm trying to
tell you bro yeah i don't care if it's
obama i don't care if it's buying him a
coach trump you're making a quarter
million dollars a year
it's on you to make the right decisions
i i agree you need to know the
difference between wants and needs
you're familiar with the acronym henry
h-e-n-r-y henry high earners not rich
yet you're a high earner you're making
250 000 a year
okay
choice is yours buddy do you want to
spend 150 and save 100 grand or do you
want to spend 280 and take on 30 grand
in debt the choice is yours do you need
to drive a mercedes do you need to live
in a three-bedroom high-rise condo so
the choice is yours right know the
difference between wants and needs do
you feel bad for anyone making a quarter
million dollars a year not a paycheck no
not at all
yeah okay 50 of millennials who make a
hundred grand or more are living
paycheck to paycheck i don't feel i
don't feel bad for them they want to
have a rolex they want to drive a nice
car i get it
but they don't it's called lifestyle
creep the more money you make the more
you feel like well i deserve to have a
nicer car i'm working hard i deserve to
move into a nicer area i deserve to go
on vacation to mykonos this summer all
my friends are going to ibiza you know
so but is that the reason make the right
decision
but and i i agree 100 but the average
american isn't making 250 000
a year average americans the voters that
are actually
getting hit the hardest and i feel you
they're not out there buying bentley
you're right [ __ ] like that the i'm the
average american bro i'm not making that
[ __ ] let me tell you and it's [ __ ]
hard i went and i've interviewed quote
unquote the average americans who got
stimulus checks they were down in south
beach and when everyone was shut down in
20 20 21 they all got stimulus checks i
remember i interviewed this was crazy
yeah i interviewed a girl i said hey uh
did you get your what was it 1400
stimulus check what was it yeah like 14.
okay um didn't qualify doubt you
qualified either i said uh what's up you
you got a four she goes nope i got fifty
six hundred i go oh what the [ __ ] i got
i got kids i get dependents oh
how much did this trip cost you well
fifty six hundred i'm like well yeah
there you go yeah she took her entire
stimulus check and she went to south
beach and partied she could have put
that into a retirement account she could
have paid off debt
i don't feel bad for people we're not
living in in some poor country in the
middle of africa they're starving with
water like you're you're in freaking
america you make 50 grand a year figure
it out i'm not saying that things aren't
tough i'm not saying that economic times
aren't in peril i'm not saying that but
we're still in america you're not
poor you're broke there's a difference
poor is i live in the middle of africa i
make no i'm living a hut correct broke
is i make 50 grand a year and i can't
get ahead
maybe you get a roommate maybe you don't
drive a mercedes and you just drive a
used car maybe you don't live in a nice
you know two-bedroom place downtown you
split like i don't feel bad for working
americans
meaning like there's options out there
you're still in america okay i
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck
i've interviewed so many of these people
that
take their stimulus checks and they go
party in south peace listen there's
different kinds of diets okay there's
different kind of diets i'll give you a
few diets i've gone up okay
one diet i went on is uh i was 25 years
old 24 25 years and went to highland
uh in hollywood club had just opened up
this is 18 years ago 19 years ago and it
was like the place to be
i went there one of my friends uh x was
there with another guy
and he goes to say hi to the girl the ex
comes pushes him we got into a big fight
and beer bottle is being thrown i'm on
top of a guy it's pretty nasty cops show
up they arrest they they have all of us
in like what do you call it okay that's
right yeah and i said to the cop i said
listen you got to let me go you'll i
swear i said you let me go i swear to
god you'll never see me here ever again
he says what do you mean i said i have
big plans in my life you got to let me
go i'm telling you i swear to god you
will never see me here ever again
i don't know why the cop let me go just
got the chills man
i see it that's [ __ ] right there my
entire body just got chills wow i said i
swear to god you will never see me here
ever again i never went back again clubs
was out of my life
i've been on a club diet since then yeah
when i was uh going and doing this bible
study with this guy in past pasadena i
heard this one guy talk about the fact
that go on a sex diet
and for me my biggest obsession was
women at the time that was my biggest
distraction so guess what i did
no sex 17 months you know how hard that
is for a guy that that's like his older
how are you i'm 24 years old that's
jesus yeah
so i go now that happens and i went on a
pure
i'm done yeah don't call me 18 months 17
months you've done the same thing 17
months but it wasn't like uh your own
decision that was no my pickup line was
just [ __ ] it was horrible
if you've seen vinnie's pictures then
he's one of the most handsome guys i
love you very good looking guys stop but
but the point is i went on that diet
okay next diet the diet was
i am no longer having the lightweight
conversations with people that all they
want to do is [ __ ] and complain about
life and blaming everybody i'm going on
a diet when friends who were constant
complainers negative being around other
people that blame their bosses blame
everybody i said dude we can't do lunch
anymore this would be the last time that
was the third diet then when i wanted to
get married and i wanted to live a life
of being married with kids i had a
single diet then i said i can't hang out
with single people anymore because your
language of a single person is a single
person's language a single person talks
in a different way than a married person
does if i have aspirations of having a
family i'm going on a singles diet it
doesn't matter no matter where you are
right now whatever your
advice vices today if it's video games
if it's women if it's drugs if it's
alcohol if it's whatever you got
it's time to go on your diet and not
tell nobody about it until two three
years later when you're winning kicking
everyone's ass then you say here's what
i did the last three years because while
you're going through it no one cares so
he went on a diet
definitely not the 17-month diet but he
went on a diet and a diet he went on
got him to have a million dollars in
cash savings
good for him but there's a diet you go
through with that okay his diet could
have been cars that could have been
different types of things right but
people can say whatever they want to say
the one reality when you're looking at
the stat about a quarter million earners
not the 50
look there's a very simple philosophy
that i go by nothing lasts forever let
me explain what i mean by that
if you're winning and you're making say
this is your biggest you make a million
eight don't assume you're gonna make a
millionaid for the rest of your life
thanks
assume that million eight is really
three hundred thousand dollars save
seven hundred thousand dollars of it set
it aside
if you're on top of the world and you're
the hottest girl and you're attractive
20 to 23 years old and you're at your
peak let me tell you something you are
never going to look as good as you do
today okay
if you're the 26 year with the abs the
muscles all this stuff you're like oh my
look
okay you ain't gonna look that like
forever okay eventually those looks are
gonna go away this doesn't mean i'm in
the best shape i've been since i was 24
years old and i feel great
but i'm not i don't look like i did when
i was 21 22 23 years old not even close
on what i looked like at that age and
i'm totally fine with it military
top-notch shape i'm not in that shape
today right so nothing lasts forever
however one thing does
legacy
history
doing something big that's written about
and talked about the only way you and i
get to live forever is by the legacy we
leave behind with the work that we do
professionally with the kids that we
raise with the relationships that we
build with the companies that we build
with the books that we write with the
articles that we write that make an
impact on people's lives that's one way
where you can live forever all this
other stuff that people are chasing one
day they're going to go away and you're
going to sit and you're going to realize
what currency was really the most
valuable what the hell was i doing so
obsessed about that thing man i'm so
over it i want to go live a big life so
pick and choose your diet whichever one
it is then go light it up that was all
now as i sort of got pat first of all
when you said you had goosebumps that
was deja vu to me i don't know if that
means we had this or this was supposed
to happen another life whatever and then
you said pick the diet as you were
saying it and you're saying don't tell
it to nobody no i already have the one
that i have and i hope everybody else is
listening to as you were saying that i
already know the one thing that i have
to just
yeah okay everything you said was
completely spot-on and it's it's
like one of the things i always say when
it comes down to money management or
whether it's accountability 50 percent
is
knowledge all right i know what i need
to do i know you know
what i got to do i got to stop eating
donuts i got to work out i got to save
money the other 50 though is behavioral
are you actually going to do it that's
the problem with the complainers out
there and with the
victim mentality they didn't do it oh my
boss this oh my friend oh why don't they
it's like mother eff you have to do it
oh are we having caviar
knowledge 50 behavior the hard part is
to actually do it to actually read the
books to actually not have sex for
17 months somehow to actually say
save your money this is hilarious listen
that's the heart like don't love your
means more [ __ ] caviar listen
everybody this is a gift
by maral and becky marlon thank you for
this caviar it's a gift so i appreciate
john that was that was fantastic so okay
let's continue let's continue another
one these are great no question about it
i'll get you so let's continue with the
next story here uh joe rogan let's talk
about joe rogan joe rogan claims
desantis would be a good president
refers to biden as a dead man president
uh page five let's see what joe's got to
say about this
during the last episode of joe rocking
experience the host joe rogan said that
governor desantis would work as a good
president rogan spoke from a former
female ufc fighter
and star wars the mandalorian star gina
carano for his latest interview at one
point the topic of uh their talk turned
to current events and the current
president of the office who rogan
referred to as a dead man president yeah
so all this stuff is happening while we
have a dead man president rogan adding
as exasperated it's not fun so even
rogan is a fan of desantis when we were
in jacksonville you know who came to see
him perform so desantis came and watched
him do his comedy show well you guys
were there with us
and then when the fight happened in in
jacksonville guess who came to the fight
the santa cruz de santis de santas went
to the comedy and he went to
the ufc and did you hear what trump said
yesterday do you hear what trump said
you said about the santas what do you
say watch this one just put trump
desantis and go to news what trump said
about the santas yesterday check this
out
trump uh uh where he says i actually can
see myself being i think uh desantis
would be a great running mate as a vp oh
yeah oh he said that
trump doesn't rule out running with
desantis as his vp i get along with them
because being negative right now
wouldn't work yeah exactly yeah what do
you think what do you think about that
comment like it's you know i see him as
a vp like well how do you process that
because okay let's be uh hey he's the
egomaniac we all know that and we're
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie
trump was crazy polarizing whatever the
economy all the policies were good but i
mean he does have a fan base i
personally want desantis to be the
president that's just hands down but if
trump runs again trump could only go for
one more term right if you can only go
for one more term i mean why not you're
setting up the sentence to you know keep
that going for
you know the next for 12 years yeah 12
more years so i mean it could be it
could be good but i mean i i don't from
who do we talk to that time you had here
pat the the girl that was his press
nicki freed or not
the christine when she was like
it's too early to talk about it she
doesn't she didn't want to mention it
yeah but i felt like she had something
in her pocket where she's like he would
run and he does want to run but i mean i
i think it might be a good strategy to
be like listen i'm definitely going to
go i'm probably going to win because the
way that everything is all jacked up
right now and then you'll just just wait
in the wings and then you'll get
you know i mean you'll get the eight
years after me i think it's an olive
branch he's suddenly saying something
halfway positive about desantis remember
three months ago desantis was
unappreciative that's what trump said
about it remember that and so he was
pushing back like he was trying to keep
him out of the field of play
three months four months ago now that
he's in the field of play polls are
proving it he's putting out this olive
branch i'm the big dog come run with me
we win
i think that's where it's going i agree
i don't know
um
i think i think trump is still the lead
guy no matter what i think trump trump
dude his endorsement record i don't know
if you're following his endorsement
record
he's like 140 and 11. i mean he's better
than the 97 98 chicago goals the record
he's good
he's 141 and 11 on the endorsements he
made you have to know there's weight
behind his voice
um because look at his camera pat his
campaign not to cut you off his
campaign's gonna be like what did i tell
you look at the [ __ ] do you want me
maybe this campaign you're right can
actually be i told you so i told you so
right you're and you're very correct
about you know how i measure it pat i
measure it that the one that he didn't
get in georgia cnn covered it for three
weeks yeah right this is trump's
endorsement didn't work remember the guy
in georgia and they're like wait a
minute why are they screaming about this
one
yeah this one no three weeks no it's
because they're scared to death listen
people can't say whatever they want
michelle obama has a voice
with you like michelle obama if michelle
obama goes out there on the campaign
trail
she's got weight when obama shows up
he's got weight when trump shows up he's
got weight i don't care if you like
trump or if you like obama and i don't
care if you don't like them
there is weight behind their voice when
they show up and trump's trump still has
it now trump is claiming he's going to
come out and announce that he's running
this month oh wow he wants to make an
early announcement yeah he wants to make
an early like this month that's going to
be july that's what roger stone said he
was going to do well there's an article
that also came out i don't know if roger
said oh roger said that as well last
week and i project uh that he's going to
say something in july an article just
came out as well that said that that's
how what's this in the world he hasn't
pushed back on the polls the polls with
the desantis are going up i can't let
this get to the mid i agree with that
and get and get up no thank you i also
let
ten points over me i have to declare now
to clear the deck and they're and their
only thing to kind of because i remember
we we got the russian collusion thing
was for you know the whole got the whole
freaking presidency the january sixth
thing where is that did that finish i
know they had some girls i think it's so
good they're still going on where
they're like he grabbed the wheel and
said let's go and then all the cnn mini
series now yeah it's it's insane so i
mean they don't really have much on them
except this you know democracy let me
tell you that nobody cares and let's
let's talk about who trump had as his vp
before mike pence mike pence was quiet
he stood in the background he wasn't
very loud he wasn't vocal he was kind of
just there yeah he was around the
scientist he had a fly on his head for
like an hour florida is the hottest
state in the nation right now by far
desantis is loud he's opinionated he's
strong in his beliefs i think mike pence
scared the [ __ ] out of donald trump and
one more electoral vote than last time
wait you said i think mike pence scared
the [ __ ] out of him absolutely i don't
think that trump felt that mike pence
was loud enough was vocal enough would
defend him was it really really could
stand up for himself i think trump wants
somebody that's basically like donald
trump not as polarizing but we'll stand
up we'll punch back we'll take the
swings we'll do what has to be done and
stand up no there's a reason that that
uh trump selected
mike pence out of nowhere
in 2016. and it's because he was the
exact what do you mean he got him
elected and it got him not an
evangelical base in the midwest he was
very calculated he picked the exact
opposite of him if you recall i'm going
back to 2016. you're probably still in
college then but let me tell you
something
he speci he could have picked christy he
could have picked any number one of
those candidates ben carson and he said
let me get the most
white bred middle american
stoic non-drama
are you saying it was a bad choice no
i'm saying it was a great job i thought
it was a great choice and it's
specifically because he was not
a new yorker trump like christy so what
i'm saying is like i hear what you're
saying in hindsight 2020 he wants
someone a little more bombastic hit back
but the whole like this is the ironic
thing about mike pence
he was the most loyal
boot-licking vice president like he was
just like you know that's my present
like he was stand by your man and then
the ironic part is you know now
he wants to hang him at the end if you
know your presidential history that's
why nixon chose agnew and that's why
hillary chose quick around the room who
she choose oh who's a weird guy
exactly right
well when she selected him i'm like
who's this loser he's like he was scary
his smile and that guy scared you but
the uh there's the point
history is making your point you're
right i agree uh the the thing that no
one wants to talk about here not here
but like
whether you agree with me or not
all good
trump is still talking so here's a
question trump is still toxic desantis
is not toxic to most americans yeah adam
you are absolute disaster so if you're
watching this i'm actually really
curious give a thumbs up
if you agree
with the fact that trump and desantis
are gonna run together if you think it's
gonna happen i don't know if it's gonna
happen but if you think it's gonna
happen give us a thumbs up i'm looking
at the numbers right now i don't know
how many people believe that'll happen
and i don't believe desantis would agree
with to that
i don't even think the call but now
here's the thing you got to realize
when's the last time two people with
massive personalities
agreed to be the vp and the vp could
have beaten the candidate you know was
the last time that happened
lbj and john f kennedy couldn't stand
each other and john f kennedy went to
lbj and said uh i want you to be my vpn
it's like who the hell are you i'm
supposed to tell you i want you to be my
vp right this guy's like you kidding me
you think you irish family this this
that and that's how it happened how did
that work out for jfk as well there's a
lot of conspiracy i think we can
interview him but
it didn't work out well i mean obviously
that's the story but but yeah but listen
but desantis and lbj are not the same
human beings lbj
is a qualified qualified
dirt bag that is not the case with who
uh desantis is but why like
complete hypothetical if you're desantis
yeah and you're becoming a trailblazer
right you you became a superstar you
know
during covid you're creating this legacy
do you actually want your legacy to be
tied directly with trump or do you want
to be like trump adjacent hey thanks for
all you've done i'm gonna do my own
thing follow me keep in mind trump is 76
years old desantis is 43 years old does
he want his entire legacy tied to trump
or does he want to carve his own path i
think i think he wants to carve his own
i think the time frame because like the
tantus is hot as hell right now this
next two years i still still think he'll
be up there because they're still we're
still dealing with colvin [ __ ] and biden
said and i quote there's gonna be a
second pandemic not maybe there might be
joe biden's second i think he went off
script we're definitely going to have a
second pandemic unless that happens
because you know
desantis is the best that santa's like
whatever they're saying come to florida
we don't give a [ __ ] and that's one of
the reasons that i'm here but but my
point being i think he
i think he was he will get on with him
and keep that [ __ ] going and then people
like we love him they obviously love
trump and then when trump was done in
four years we're gonna deal with it for
four years the santa's gonna take over
but i'm telling easies when you say when
you say they obviously love trump who
are you talking
do the republicans
well yeah worship
the santa's right and then having him
being right there bro their mentality's
gonna be like four years with trump and
then guess what boom we're gonna have
another eight with desantis and that's a
right only republicans are voting yeah i
agree
but there's like a whole other half of
the country that you still have to win
over first of all i think there's a huge
percentage of the population that likes
desantis and doesn't think he's as toxic
as trump and
again i agree with you trump is
exceptionally toxic like exceptionally i
agree i agree the people want somebody
who's gonna fight for them and stand up
and punch back and i don't think they
want another mike pence i don't think
donald trump wants another mike pence i
don't think he wants a chris christie i
don't think there's anybody else in the
party that he could pick to run with he
wants a mike tyson and roy jones that's
what they want they want those two
running it and then when mike tyson
retires in a perfect world it's all well
and good to pick somebody on the
policies but this isn't the world we
live in we live in a world with joe
biden and kamala harris and a democratic
left party that's gonna trash everybody
slam you throw mud sling mud throw water
there's no more rolling over and playing
it's both parties though tyler everyone
does that trump you don't think trump
but trump but who else
who else in the party does trump trump
trump is the only person in the party
that anyone's even concerned about
nobody cares about anyone else other
than trump in the republican party but
and then possibly desantis okay but and
then if you look at the other side you
have nancy pelosi kamala joe biden gavin
newsom uh
adam schiff you go down the line
everybody's throwing mud everybody's
slamming you don't think you don't think
uh lindsey graham is throwing mud you
don't think jim jordan is throwing mud
you don't think uh i think jim jordan
marjorie taylor green is throwing much
come on
everyone's doing it jewish space lasers
so i don't take a lot like i take
everything she says with a grain of salt
but no i mean there's she's got a voice
this is my point
yeah so it's politics is a dirty
business we learned that from roger
stone
i don't know if trump's going to pick
him as a vp who would you think no i i
think he's going to pick somebody that's
a very
non you know it's going to be somebody
you least expect and it's probably going
to be somebody that's not even on the
stage like not even like a rubio or
somebody like no rubio he will never
ever rubio rubio's not a he would never
take rubio and by the way i totally
agree with you yeah you have to like
i'm not even dissing trump right here i
think this is a factual statement the
man has a humongous ego
humongous ego yeah so if you have a
desantis they're waiting in the ring in
the wings what do you think that does
for someone with a massive ego if
especially if he's a vp he's a threat
paranoid he wants exactly paranoia is
going to set in what's he looking over
my shoulder if you have someone like a
pence who
but
when trump was dealing with the worst of
the worst stuff
you know hurricane in puerto rico
whatever any issue uh the charlotte's
but whatever issue was facing pence
stood there and said that's my man i
defend him at all costs that is what
trump wants and the where trump where
pence fell
fell off is that the final day at the
final countdown when he needed pence to
be like hey no you're still the
president pence said no you're all right
brother you lost bro and that was the
death of pence he needs someone a
loyalist till the end do you think if uh
tulsi gabbard switches sides and she
could be good wouldn't happen he would
never picked us never he would never
pick tulsi no
he he wants a c-o-o that's not too loud
that's who he wants he doesn't want
somebody that's too loud he wants a
quiet c-o-o that gets the job done yeah
that's who he's looking for they'll be
outstaged by the santas the sanchez is a
rock no way even if it's one percent
outstage he doesn't want that in his
life he wants it to be about him
somebody else that's a true believer
that's a flag carrier that's going to
get him
to make his job easier and that that's
he's by the way he's already got a
handful of names that he's thinking
about he would never tell anybody who it
is but he's already got a handful look
at the states
that are tipping points like what states
are up for grabs
you know some place in the rust belt
some place in the midwest whatever's
going to be up for grabs
assuming he runs whatever that's where
you need to look it's the same four okay
same four wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania ohio it is this is
all those examples
so look there for where let's move on
let's move on from this story let me
tell you guys why cnn keeps losing clout
and i you know the the new leader of cnn
says well we're going in a different
direction we're going to start doing
reporting show the article i just sent
you about recession
you you tell me how this reads i just
texted it to you okay
so you would think like okay
they're going to talk about recession
and they're going to say different
opinions and they're going to say well
people disagree and it's going to be a
reasonable route nope look at look at
this title actually zoom in
who decides if the u.s is in recession
eight white economists you've never
heard of what what
what do you mean eight what does white
have to do with recession and this is
scenario and you wonder like you wonder
why people are sick of your
games
just say eight economists you've never
heard of before that that one word white
is why people are sick of you
that one simple because it's this that's
exactly this division that's exactly how
you get people angry to think the white
people are saying there's a recession
can you go up a little bit go up a
little bit let's actually read this
article to see how it's written oh open
it up a little bit zoom in a little bit
more so i say the the people's names
probably yeah prominent wall street uh
economists like uh mark zandy investing
luminaries like arkansas cattywood and
kathy wood and executives like jp morgan
chad jamie diamond can make recession
predictions until they're blue in the
face but their guidance will remain just
at an economic forecast that's because
in the united states the economy isn't
broadly unofficially considered to be a
recession until a relatively unknown
group of eight economists say so the
economists who serve together as
business cycle dating committee are hand
selected by the working under umbrella
of net national bureau of economic
research a private nonprofit
organization
they are have no predetermined meeting
dates and their
deliberations are i mean what are you
what are you saying and look there's no
recession unless these guys say so
yeah
that's the one right there there's a
clear lack of racial diversity among the
eight members it's race
cnn yeah when it comes down to recession
there is no color
then nobody says well in order for us to
finalize recession we need to have one
black one hispanic one iranian somebody
from the lgbtq that's the only way
recession is real stop playing these
games no and if you want to hold on i
said none of them are so
ridiculous when they do this
so ridiculous when they do this and by
the way
keep doing it
keep doing it if you forgot why cnn plus
didn't work with 300 million dollars in
small little startups like you know uh
what's ben shapiro's company's name
daily wireless and you got these other
companies that are coming up they're
whooping your ass
and it's not gonna slow down by the way
you keep playing games with americans
who just want some information and you
keep trying to say it's division right
what a pathetic article right you're
trying to create division i'm a
pathetic article right there i'm 100
agreements with you 100 they're playing
identity politics like why why even
listen i don't care if you're blue i
don't care if you're red when it comes
to the economy it's all about the green
you're playing identity politics
like i don't just ten leading economists
eight leading economists said this
period i don't care if they're black
white yellow green jewish catholic like
give me some give me some actual
substance what's the next next eight
they're five eight and under like how
they're gonna talk about height it's
like bro relax bro that's insane that's
too much you see when you do stuff like
that you talk none of these people say
anything gases and eight bucks a gallon
in l.a okay what are your thoughts on
this it says african americans account
for 13 of the u.s population but only
three percent okay of economists well
let me know
what's stopping you from becoming an
economy wait a minute wait a minute okay
let's play that right let's play that
game sure can you can you tell me uh
white people account for
60 of the population yet only 11 of the
nba
you're right is the nba racist yeah why
don't you let white people play there uh
america accounts for 24 hispanic but the
nba is only one percent hispanic what a
racist organization i think less than
one percent but what i'm trying to say
to you is
see when but by the way
a comment like that
for people who
don't really really read into it they're
like oh that's right [ __ ] racist
you deserve to be more black economist
then guess guess what go become an
economy by the way it is way easier to
become an economist than it is to become
an nba player 1 000 just so you know
yeah 1 000
yeah they're they're done bro it's like
i love the analogy you just gave there
because anyone with their head on
straight will be like well yeah
obviously because you know they're not
like as good as the tall seven foot
black guys playing basketball yeah you
just because of your color or your
belief or your belief system you don't
deserve a job yeah it's supposed to be
it's a meritocracy
yeah i'm 100 with you on pads and
knowing as hell
it's not going to stop though but but
it's not going to stop what they're
saying can you go to the part about
rescinding jobs go to that one go to the
wall street journal article because this
is
this is a little weird this is stuff
we've not heard of before just take it
from the text i sent you go back to it
and go from there instead of looking for
your 75 tabs that you have that will
take you 18 minutes
just go to the text i sent you and just
pull that one up because this one is
interesting folks
uh
ah
where's the article let me see where
it's at if i have it even here on my
page hang on there you go okay
so wall street journal
you don't have the article no i don't
think he said it to me
but this this should be it right here
that's the one
more companies start to rescind job
offers okay go a little closer and go
lower to read the first line right there
that's the line go a little closer today
good companies including twitter
redfin
coinbase have rescinded offers in recent
weeks employees and other pockets of the
economy are pulling away offers too
including insurance retail marketing
consulting and recruiting services okay
so
you know like by the way just just out
of curiosity if you're watching this or
even you guys here
tom you've been around and you follow
the economy closely yep when's the last
time you heard an article that says
companies are rescinding job offers
um
10 minutes after the crash at the fourth
quarter of 2008 is where everybody made
the sudden adjustment right the money
tightened up everybody pulled job offers
it's been 13 years
to recent job offers so so to the
average person that's listening to this
explain to us what that looks like what
is resending job offers okay so you have
a company that's got 500 employees and
up at the top you've got finance people
and everything and they're looking at
sales looking at sales come in it's a
little weak meanwhile down on the third
floor the hr department's trying to
recruit people per the plan that they
set a month ago and they're recruiting
them and at the same moment they're
recruiting they're realizing sales
numbers are soft and they're realizing
that the economy is tough so when they
yell stop
already there were people that were in
that hiring process that were going
through getting their drug tests and
everything to get hired and they're
having to call them back saying hey i'm
really sorry i just made you a job offer
but we have put a hiring freeze on
retroactively and i have to pull the
offer back so you see what i mean the
statistics and the j the change in the
economy pat is happening so fast
that as they see sales and they see
what's happening to the economy and
they're yelling stop
even as downstairs was working to hire
good people finding really good people
to come in and they're having to say the
people that we're about to give two
weeks notice or maybe three weeks old if
you get great people sometimes they want
to give three weeks notice to a prior
job they're having to go to those people
and say
you gotta see if they'll take you back
because i have to pull the offer
it's happening so fast pat that that's
what's happening the rescind is
happening because the economy is moving
downward fast i can't imagine saying to
somebody like hey listen pat i i
thank you i'm going to another company
they're going to be paying me
a lot more i'm giving you my three weeks
notice and they're like okay cool you
know still kind of some some tension
there and then i come back i'm like
listen pat
uh i need you back
i have to come back here is it okay
biology like i if you were you wouldn't
be like first of all no way and if there
was any way that you're going to come
you know pissed off that person would be
like you listen listen yeah for half of
what you were going to get i'd be a dick
i'd be like oh you you just bounced and
now that's what a point you mean the
former company 100
yeah what is the former company gonna
yeah no no i don't you already took
another one no but yeah but pat but i
love this job come on like i didn't know
they were gonna do that i know they're
gonna rescind so now we're gonna [ __ ]
always leave on good terms and always
leave friendly always offer referrals
two ways you never know who you're going
to need that's insane
that would be so awkward hey guys we got
a new guy but he's not new he's back
vinnie's back again that's great you
know
or vinnie come back to me vinnie you
know two weeks since you
gave notice yeah we're also seeing sales
down a little bit and everything and
actually we're not going to replace your
position we had already talked about
with you leaving maybe we janitor
i clean the bathroom really good easy do
you see what could be happening for sure
yeah for sure
what are the odds that you probably
stayed in the same industry where you
knew people and you got a next job with
another competitor company exactly and
the economy's hitting that side they
said vinnie i'm really sorry we just
figured out we're just not going to
replace you that's insane bro yeah
zuckerberg also said the same thing
where they're letting people go
uh amid warning
meta downsizing
hiring plans amid warning of layoffs
uh uh
by the way this is a i'm gonna text you
this article if you want to pull this up
it's an epoch times article but they do
this stuff that you got to put your
email it takes a while to pull that
article up didn't bezos and zuckerberg
just start talking here zuckerberg we're
turning up the heat at meta so employees
will quit jesus what yeah that's exactly
good you really said that go little go
zoom in facebook parent meta
wants to cut ties with workers who can't
meet newly raised performance
expectations as a company prepares for
an economic downturn
zuck's uh
frank admission came during the q a
session with employees in which he
warned that a recent slump in the
markets might be
one of the worst downturns we've seen in
recent history this is coming from
zuckerberg realistically there are
probably a bunch of people at the
company who shouldn't be here
can you imagine saying that to reuters
like those of you who are playing cheryl
sandberg's wedding you're out
part of my hope by raising expectations
and having more aggressive goals and
just kind of turning up the heat a
little bit is that i think some of you
might think that this place isn't for
you and that self selection is okay with
me i actually love
that position he took love go a little
bit higher zuckerberg indicated that
meta plans to slow its hiring process
hiring platform engineers at least by
thirty percent roughly adding six to
seven thousand workers rather than ten
thousand it initially expected to hire
some roles that are currently empty will
stay unfilled as meta dials up pressure
on current employees you're right what
do you think about that when you hear
that what do you think about it adam i
mean you've said pretty candidly that
most companies should fire the bottom
twenty percent
right i mean so the good news is if
you're in the top eighty percent yeah
you can keep your job you know they say
warren buffett has said this before so
of other you know great luminaries in
the economy there's one way to be
recession proof or inflation-proof and
that's just to be [ __ ] good at what
you do
have a straight-up skill set and be good
at it if you're kind of lollygagging and
you know just there's a difference
between a job and a career if you're a
career and you become a specialist
and you're constantly improving and and
and getting better and
showing loyalty to the company and you
want to be there you're not going to get
fired and if you do you'll find another
option but if you're in the bottom 20
bottom 40 percent you don't really
kind of take your job seriously
you know
again the individual responsibility
whatever would you expect to have you're
so right the top third has nothing to
worry about the middle third maybe get
nervous
the bottom third should be terrified
mm-hmm
simple as that yeah i mean
you i don't remember the number you said
exactly i don't know if it was 10 20 12
percent
30 you think that bottom 30 should be
fired
i think for every time somebody comes in
and says
you know if a boss comes in and says
these three people deserve a raise okay
cool sounds good how much of a raise are
like if you're running a real business
these three people deserve a raise
fantastic
and you got 100 employees
and by the way this is going to sound
cold but if you've never ran a business
you haven't operated no problem you can
have your opinion go operator business
and then you'll see what it's like when
you have to hit margins and expenses and
all these other things you deal with hey
man if you come and say we gotta give
these three people a raise
and we got to hire three more people
that's a great that's a great plan so
tell me which one or two people do we
have to let go wow what do you mean well
you just came to me asking me to hire
three more people right okay and you
told me to increase the so revenues if
it doesn't match the revenue that we're
growing
if you ask me to get more employees but
the revenues increase isn't at that pace
or not higher then you have to also come
up to me and say here's the two people i
also recommend we move on with okay cool
no problem so this is what it should
sound like a real manager should come up
and say hey tom
uh i got adam i think deserves he's
crushed the last two quarters i think we
need to bump him up from 80 to 92 and
then i think
tyler's crushed it i think we need to
increase tyler as well and i think we
need to hire three new people uh one
engineer one bi analyst and one
processor and this is what we need to do
and then at the same time uh this person
that we have in this department who's an
engineer i think is not the best called
in six seven times in the last four
months
and it's usually late and the attitude
isn't necessarily there and we've asked
him up and we've sent him emails a
couple of times written them up i think
we need to let him go and this other
person that's working over here as a
processor
i don't think they like their job and
they complain to everybody and they're
very negative so i think we need to also
let those people go you approach your
boss that way the boss is going to be
like oh
okay give those guys a raise and hire
those three people you know what i would
say
yeah you know what i'd say probably
you'd say i would say hey pat thank you
very much for that um obviously you
follow the nba and you know they have a
salary cap and most sports now have
salary caps
i really appreciate the way you're
managing this with the salary cap you're
trying to put the best team on the field
with the salary cap you're gonna pay
some stars and you're gonna cut some
players because you stay with the salary
cap during this economic downturn you're
gonna get a bonus at the end of the year
thank you for thinking that way because
that's the way i have to think pat with
a salary cap every day and then pat goes
up to me and goes now you're gone
because he gets the bonus
out of here i like what you did there
with the nba analogy salary cap because
it's
if the salary cap is you know 100
million dollars a year make up a number
10 million dollars whatever it is
that's your number that's so if you want
to hire more people and give you more
raises
somebody's got to let go now in the nba
you might say well there's a luxury tax
no there is luxury tax that's my point
exactly you're losing money and you
can't there you go by the way it's a
hard it's back in the old days that what
they call the hard cap
hardcount can you imagine how many
people complain about the nba when they
fire the bottom who are not performing
and they go higher to top who are
performing who complains in the nba
nobody nobody but god forbid that's you
god forbid you do what do you think is
the difference both of them are
businesses exactly exactly both of these
man just had uh two points seven
turnovers and
a technical foul it's like well
we gotta let him go
not only that how come haslam never gets
fired how come has them have a great
attitude shows up to work everybody
shows up to worry about
sitting there talking to the young guy
saying listen drop those three girls be
careful getting that one pregnant
hero didn't listen and you got a couple
other people that are going through this
but you're having that conversation with
the people right okay he's a player
coach he's a player coach exactly you
stay on the team you were going to say
something i just i wonder on that point
if there's a layer deeper to this that
you see
uh facebook this is a little old but
facebook's their their users decline
okay you're seeing elon musk buying
twitter
cleaning people out people revolting he
fired the people at spacex who spoke out
against him um you're seeing jeff bezos
have his spats with uh the the
administration i wonder if these
business owners
are starting to get sick and tired of
the inmates running the asylum and this
is a convenient excuse i wonder if
they're starting to push back and say
listen this is my company i'm tired of
the culture i'm tired of the toddlers
and babysitting all day we're gonna
clean house we're gonna make this work
you're affecting my bottom line and i'm
sick of it by the way um good point say
that's it
i support it go for it yeah i support it
because sometimes
one time it's 2013 2014.
i am afraid of losing my entire company
i as the founder ceo i am scared
i'm having panic and anxiety attacks
every night because the business is
about to go from what it is to losing
100 of people
and i'm leading through fear and i'm
walking on eggshells so i'm afraid to
challenge my guys too much because they
may leave me
and i'm afraid to set my standards and
they're now telling me how to lead
they're telling me that you should do
this you should do that you should do
this so what happens for a year and a
half
talk to jennifer and you'll see i'm like
oh my god i'm like yeah hey so you guys
are awesome also you guys are great oh
my god no no and what i'm like
i'm so sick of your like
stop
you're a leader
go back to leading
if they don't want to do anything no
problem but you're going to find the
right guys
i turn them to turn up the heat switch
my work ethic is the same it's not like
i'm not working but i raised standards
to this level a couple of them didn't
like that
couple of them were okay with that and
couple people who were not players
went to levels that we never thought
they were going to go to the company
took off right but sometimes a zuck or a
dorsey or anybody
will go through the fear of man what if
we lose that guy what if we lose the
scout what if we lose that guy you know
sometimes like even when you're creating
content sometimes you're like man i
can't say that because if i say that
what if we never interviewed that guy
yeah i can't say all right because we
need that guy
oh what we need
be respectful
give your thoughts
don't play games
don't manipulate
don't be divisive
you know straight up show up
do your best to constantly improve
realize you don't walk on water and then
all of a sudden you're looking around
you're saying we've got some great
people around us we have a very good
environment here people are having fun
people are working and those who don't
want to work hard and those who don't
want to have fun and those are
this is not the place for you and that's
totally fine and if zuck is going
through that guess what i say to him
salute good job good for you good for
you for standing up on what's not
working out what is this netflix netflix
alters corporate culture memo to stress
the importance of artistic freedom it's
a little older but it's remember when
netflix did this couple months ago yeah
listen if you don't like the content too
damn bad go [ __ ] go somewhere else yeah
you're going to make a while yeah it
took a while until they did that it cost
them how many users
it cost them all remember that one day
when their stock dropped like 40 percent
everybody and their mothers was talking
about that
finally they realized leadership is hard
you do you listen you don't like it go
elsewhere and it only took a 50 billion
dollar drop to be like oh [ __ ] being
woke and and pandering to everybody it's
like bro yeah as a comedian pat i go i
don't i'm not saying i don't give a [ __ ]
about people's feelings but it's my
experience my idea and i think there's
been a big lack of this is my opinion
what i say isn't factual you're not the
fact check everything a human being says
this is what i think you could think a
certain way adam has a certain way i'm
in front of an audience this is your
audience i'm a comedian i'm writing
sketches i'm shooting [ __ ] it's this is
my idea of what funny is and this is
what interesting if you don't like it
change the channel don't change the
goddamn company right because you don't
you think a certain little group isn't
going to like yeah but you're funny as
hell bro
let me let me tell you there's certain
people like
that
want to be funny and are not funny
and there's certain people that don't
care to be funny but are very funny
there are certain people that want to be
nba players but they suck at basketball
there are certain people that want to be
models but listen you ain't got a model
you know certain people that want to be
bodybuilders but you don't have the body
to be a bodybuilder
you're a comedian okay and it's very
natural and it's non-stop from the
beginning to the end and it's proven it
so
by the way shout out to vitamin comedy
if you haven't subscribed go subscribe
his latest one that you did i was
watching it the other night was the
mafia not the mafia one the one with the
stabbing my friend
and then the music comes on the epic
music and then he's like bro i'm not
gonna lie it's not doing anything to me
can you do it one more time oh my god
let me do it one more time that's
hilarious it's on valuetainment comedy
please subscribe but we're gonna we just
shot another sketch i don't know if you
were here pat on friday here's what i'm
hilarious let me tell you what i got i'm
out elsewhere i don't know where i was
at but i'm out elsewhere and i get a
text saying
guys we have we have vinnie walking
around the office on a g string i said
no way
no no he is
actually i think it wasn't even for a
sketch not just
that wasn't a sketch it was g-string
friday tom you weren't and i thought it
was emails i thought it was yeah it was
absolutely
you made my point exactly i'm i'm going
to i'm trying to be funny i want to be
different i mean that character you guys
are going to see sooner or later but
like i said you don't bow down to
anybody when it comes to your art and
your job and your talent period shout
out to vinnie and vt comedy subscribe
but by the way back to the netflix the
the lead into the story that was the
height of the dave chappelle
transgender comedy
when chappelle's like look i'm not and
by the way i'm chappelle i'm gonna keep
doing what i'm doing if you're upset
with it on netflix you know kick rocks
exactly exactly right and dave chappelle
was just exhibiting his comedic genius
and artistic freedom this was not the
michael richards meltdown that happened
at the comedy club
factory where he took that life actually
over he took leave of his senses and
exposed a lot of deep biases in a trunk
that was not entertainment and they the
woke wants to make all of it the same
thing but it's not it's comedy america
needs a laugh it's artistic expression
it's freedom of speech and if you don't
like that comedy turn the channel
exactly the channel i agree 100
but by the way do we want to at all take
the risk and touch a sports story oh no
i don't know pat our audience can handle
a report such a sports story all right
all right let's go to kevin durant's
story here kevin durant is requesting
trades
and uh durant uh trade from nets and
reportedly have the leak called within
an hour uh duran may have uh set off the
biggest trade sweepstakes in nba history
durant on thursday requested a trade
from brooklyn nets according to multiple
proposed 34 years old durant is still in
mvp form coming off a season in which he
averaged 30.7 rebound six assists a game
he also has four years and about 200
million dollars left on the contract
adrian wojanovsky on nba today uh said
that more than half the nba has already
called the nets there are there was
certainly a lot of back and back
channeling going on
around the league to suggest that kevin
durant was planning to ask for uh trade
at some point and it happened today and
now i'm being told that since they're
reporting here in the last hour half the
league has reached out to him et cetera
et cetera so what do you think is going
to end up and what's going to happen
with kyrie and these guys you're
following some of this of course um well
just news flash to our friends in
brooklyn you can't buy a championship
this is the second time they've tried to
do this they did this i don't know 10
years ago with kg kevin garnett paul
pierce that crew
nothing they tried to do it again with
kevin durant uh and kyrie and hardin
didn't work out i mean we learned that
lesson back in 2004 with the lakers
when they had shaq and kobe and gary
payton and carmella try to buy a
championship
it's not the team with the best players
you're the boss you're right but you
talked about that it's the team uh the
the players they play best so maybe let
me ask a question in a different way so
okay most likely durant's going to where
they're saying it's going to go he's
going to go to miami or phoenix we'll
see okay no no not going to you don't
think it's going to go to golden state
tell me why you don't think it's going
to go to golden state uh tom's uh tom's
analogy the salary cap i mean they're
going to have to trade three people yeah
at least i don't see him going back
there okay like you don't return
by the way fyi if golden state traded
wiggins and they gave a few pieces to
get him i think it's a mistake if they
do that i think wiggins works very well
with his attitude and he's like wiggins
is a
better version of what a.i was andre
iguodala oh my gosh i think he's had
that no no no
he's playing that role very well as a
number four and it's perfect you don't
break up a team after you dude don't
even touch it don't even touch it if he
goes to miami who has to leave
oh they'll trade whoever they want other
than jimmy butler that's the only person
that's i think they trade jimmy he won't
go
no no there it'd be it'd be a
cornerstone of jimmy butler bam adebayo
and kevin durant and if he goes and then
everyone else is they're going to trade
what they're going to trade the booker
for every no no no no
the booker's untouchable so is deandre
eaton everyone expressed paul
everyone else is expected except for
deandre and except for booker yeah i
actually can see that working out
i can see that working out yeah and i
did the thing with durant without going
too sportsy here and i'm trying to make
this like a business analogy it's
you touched on this earlier legacy
legacy
durant arguably
is right neck and neck with the lebron
right neck and neck right but legacy
wise do you think durant's legacy will
be anywhere near lebron no no way not at
all
and why do you think that is lebron went
and won
uh
let's
first of all the guy won okay miami you
won those championships dwyane wade was
the leader fine
fine no problem
then you go to cleveland you're the
leader and you won okay great then you
go to the lakers and you win during
covet whatever say three and a half
championships he's got but you win you
got the championships
durant went to golden state who had
already won and you won now
kerr steph curry and all those guys
still try to give him credit oh my gosh
he did this he did that they're playing
the very clean game that they're doing
oh but durant's legacy is he's listen
he's a top 10 player of all time he's
not going to make he's not going to make
in the top five the way he's playing he
could have easily made it into a top
five his argument could have been a top
five
his decision-making process decision and
injuries is not a deal let me ask you
guys well and also he's never done this
before
there's a lot of what do you mean
players out there
well durant usually you said it his
sticks around to win a championship he's
got some loyalty there
no he doesn't you don't think so zero no
listen they're playing against golden
state he's at okc
he's with westbrook they're up 3-2
they're about to beat them they probably
would have won the championship that
year and they end up coming back and
they beat him 4-3
and you're this close you could have won
it with westbrook then you leave and go
to the team that beats you
no bro yeah that was great but it was
over yeah that was the day when it was
over where durant is like you're joining
the guys that like that doesn't make any
sense to me so look i mean listen the
nba is gonna try to go out there and get
this guy
and uh uh
i think booker is probably gonna play
with this guy or jimmy's gonna want to
play with this guy but
booker is uh
for me when i look at what's going on
with the mb like this is why i like
milwaukee bucks yeah because i like
giannis
and i like the fact that they're going
up there with a giannis middleton guys
here like who are these guys they built
these guys they built these guys i like
golden state i love what boston does i
hope boston doesn't touch and screw that
thing up don't touch it because i think
they're about to win and i actually like
what miami has done just bring a couple
other pieces now don't get me wrong guys
a miami guy yourself you probably
wouldn't mind durant coming to miami
you're going to be like you'll take them
in a heartbeat i agree but
the the story that because just because
i came from new york this past weekend
and i actually visited brooklyn
something's going on there really some i
mean
why does kd want to get out of brooklyn
why did hardin want to get out of
brooklyn they just brought in the guy uh
simmons
there's something toxic going on there
in brooklyn i don't know but they're not
as toxic as the knicks we know that
don't ever talk no first of all toxic is
a byproduct of a lack of leadership none
of those three are leaders not durant
not kyrie not hard and none of them are
leaders but i'm worried about the
leadership at the top
the owner the size
chinese guy blame it's easy to blame
situations like that going back to your
point what you said
you still gotta lead and you got to go
perform okay there is no leadership
between those three guys they're just
talents what made you pick this sports
store that you were i don't know he put
it on you i'm like let's talk about it
so okay let's talk about rachel maddow
to make you happy because i know you're
a big madoff fan oh yeah so here's
maddow maddow's story on what happened
with isn't mata supposed to be like
their superstar isn't matter like msnbc
superstar yes tyler would you say yes or
no like that's their superstar
msnbc replacing mata would previously
cancel alex wagner puzzles insiders no
institutional memory
msnbc alex wagner's rachel maddow's time
slot replacement for four days a week
the network's biggest star is not on the
air but insiders have questioned why
executives would attempt to replace mata
with a previously cancelled host who
never moved the needle on television
msnbc finished the second quarter of
2022 with its smallest audience amongst
advertisement demographic of adults ages
25 to 54 since 2003 msnbc's nearly two
decade low in the critical category came
during a jam-packed stretch of news that
included russia's ongoing invasion of
ukraine the uvalde texas school shooting
and the beginning of the january 6
committee hearings the second quarter
also featured maddow scaling back her
workload to once a week as she began
hosting the rachel maddow show only on
monday nights last month nbc selected
wagner as a former mbc msnbc host to
replace maddow
with a new program at 9pm since eastern
eastern time slot tuesdays through
friday beginning in august
what do you think msnbc is going through
right now what is this all
about as adam said i don't pay much
attention to msnbc but they're they're
i think everybody's trying to redirect
man they see tucker carlson has the
leading audience across cable television
not just in republicans and democrats as
well and they understand that people
have their numbers cnn msnbc
all those outlets they're trying to
revamp and redirect themselves i think
msnbc is tired of being the crazy joy
read rachel maddow network and they want
to do something different now i'd like
to give rachel maddow some credit we saw
the other day uh we played the clip
about her you know saying trump never
cited this insurrection so credit where
credit is due but i think i think people
want to get more of the jake tapper vibe
where yes you may be opinionated but at
least you're rational coherent you can
make an argument you can fault your own
side et cetera you're not the activist
you're just reporting the news yeah you
have your biases which we all do but
like right there pat when they said that
two-decade low happened during a
jam-packed stretch of ukraine uh
uh in the beginning of the january 6th
committee nobody wants to hear that [ __ ]
bro nobody it it's just too much it's
like you know threat to democracy i
don't know how many times i heard threat
to democracy over and over and like
people are just tired and don't forget
they're the same people that told you
there was rushing of course exactly
that's where i was going that's why
people know that they hired the former
producer from abc news to literally
produce the first week of this trial
they they know it's a it's a show trial
tom what do you think is going on here i
i think msnbc has got to find itself and
there's there's two thoughts that are in
the mind of leadership and that they
can't reconcile one is they honestly
feel they're a liberal position network
they feel they are equal time that's
what they feel and that's why they
filled it with rachel maddow who became
a hit and so many things with it
the other side of it they're looking at
the reality of tucker carlson the
reality of moderates the reality of
ratings
and they're also looking at the reality
of corporate ownership
and they are trapped they're trapped
between
the identity of what they feel msnbc is
and the ratings and the need for
commercial decisions and they're stuck
in the middle and you're seeing them
trying
you know
um trying to do it trying to put
together two who's the right person for
msnbc right now like if msnbc was to go
out there and get somebody who would be
a good person
i think the problem that msc is having
is those right people have already left
i'm who am i talking about brian
williams i thought was an absolute stud
gone do you remember his ex
of course he said this is not what i
signed up for basically that's exactly
right i was a big brian williams fan i
was also a fan of what was his name
chris matthews been on the air forever
and he got caught up in the me too
scandal what have you what happened with
him
um
msnbc much like cnn jumped on the
anti-trump train now that the train is
off the tracks what's your story now
you're not gonna just start defending
biden so they went all in on the
anti-trump uh you know campaign
trump's gone you quote unquote one you
remember don on cnn but don lemon cried
i don't care what it was
okay now what exactly i mean you gotta
still be journalists and tell the news
and tell the stories
and the facts and the the facts aren't
pretty right now do you know sauce talks
money zero
sarcasm here do you know sauce cast when
you do sauce cass you have more viewers
than don lemon does
seriously no no you're laughing
seriously you have
the same amount of viewers as don lemon
does
all right think about that when you're
doing a youtube live
you're getting the same amount of
viewers as a don lemon is getting
how are they selling advertisement on
don lemon's show how are they selling it
like what are you telling people to do
yeah
are you like who's watching that show in
the first place with don lemon so
anyways if i'm msnbc if i'm any of these
big guys
you gotta go
be heavy-duty recruiting today
and bring a new vision in that's
exciting
and you really gotta fire the bottom 30
percent of people that are hurting these
numbers and show the marketplace that
you're msnbc everybody knows your brand
but your take you've taken the wrong
angle
again pedaling trying to you know please
everybody and you're trying to make
everybody happy they don't work out
maybe a new strategy is a good place to
start right now well because if they
keep going the way they're going right
now they're going to get crushed even
more well there's a case study for you
and it's cnn
bring in jeff zucker say bring in jeff
zucker he strategically built exactly
what he wanted to build and he was not
uh
inhibited in any way
now he screwed himself up with the whole
affair thing the thing that went over
the you know that the marketing because
that was a lack of integrity
but what he built was what he said he
would build it just didn't sell the
product didn't sell you're talking about
cnn correct and cnn plus so you need to
start at the top you need to bring
someone in and set the strategy and go
and if america doesn't like that product
they're not going to watch it but that's
where it's got to go it's not going to
be could we pay tucker carlson a
trillion dollars to come across the
street and say we're going to do it you
don't start it at that level you have to
do it the way cnn did and bring in
leadership to set strategy and to put it
there and if america doesn't like what's
there as they didn't like it with jeff
then his affair and everything becomes
an excuse to also put a nail on him well
cnn they c uh cnn and msnbc should pray
to god that trump wins so they'll have
they could go back to the talking show
right then they'll get their viewers
that's a good point i'm dead serious a
really good point
they better pray to god that he wins
again so they could be like all right
the trump train's back on the [ __ ]
track and let's just bash them every day
oh
insurrection that's all they're going to
do bro so everybody that's there better
pray to god because that's what mark
zucker had it was the trump show and all
those undercover projects veritas videos
those guys are like bro that's all they
told us to do was trump trump trump bro
it worked well it worked you're by the
way you're you're you're not wrong uh at
all and you know like jeff's orange will
be the new green right
exactly that's that's true
zucker was you know famous for stirring
up controversy like he's the guy that
said oh trump's about to speak in about
a half hour just keep the cameras
rolling on the empty podium for a half
hour yeah you've seen this yeah it works
about this and just really hey what's
happening right now another thing these
legacy media companies need to embrace
is the fact that their demographic is
getting older and grayer and uh you know
won't be here around much longer you
kind of gotta tap into the the the
younger generation on youtube you
brought up the fact that is saskatchewan
as many views as don lemon all right
respect
but it's ten times more entertaining and
thank you sir not even close i'll take
it yeah yeah but the um
[Music]
you gotta cast a wider net so i guess
what i'm seeing with these with msc biz
of the world are you like the riches are
in the niches but if you're too niche
like if you're too
pigeon-holed into engine holding like
you're not gonna
um convert you're not looking at you're
not converting anybody
tucker you know he's got his base but
there's also some people he's converting
saying you know i didn't like this guy
didn't like fox news but
this guy's got a point yeah so
uh that's the challenge can you pull up
the story i just sent you pull up the
story i just texted you
uh a minute ago about newsome tweet
about florida so here's what newsome
seventh about florida
uh gavin newsom goes on the air against
ron desantis as political
rivalry grows so if you want to go a
little lower so i wonder why he's doing
this we're go a little closer let's read
this a little bit more zoom a little bit
more nussel and desantis aren't just
avatars for the different futures of the
parties but also for the separate
realities blue and red americans are
living in two people opposing viewpoints
looking at the same exact set of facts
and coming to vastly different
conclusions they are both governors
so go to what he said about florida i
want to read what he said about florida
i think it was on twitter or something
like that what he said about florida
okay there you go
it's independence day so let's talk
about what's going on in america newsom
says
uh in the ads standing in the california
sun tireless as americans the beautiful
fingerprint and the background american
is under attack in your state
those last words flash across the screen
in red followed by desantis shaking cans
with former president donald trump and
another of the floor florida governor as
newsome ticks through
uh uh florida laws to ban books and
restrict voting speech and access to
abortion i urge all of you
living in florida to join the fight or
join us in california where we will
still believe in freedom freedom of
speech freedom to choose freedom to pray
freedom to love newsome says as all
images proceed of an aerial shot of
santa monica pier to show rainbow red
flags flags waving in the hands of two
women and arms around each other don't
let them take your freedom that is paid
for by newsome re-election campaign
through this clearly
he's running for president newsome told
cnn last week i care about people i
don't like people being treated as less
of them i don't like people being told
they're not worthy i don't like people
being used as political pawns that's
because you never do that buddy yeah now
this is not just about you and never
hear you have a poster child of it we're
as different newsom said as daylight and
darkness over the course of 20 minute
phone interview newsome called desantis
bully a fraud an authoritarian a fake
conservative a betrayer of ronald
reagan's legacy several times de santos
everybody got portions of the playbook
newsome said comparing desantis to other
republicans he's writing it javanese
might as well
uh light a pile of cash on fire the
santa's campaign spokesperson david
brown said pass the popcorn for his
desperate attempt to win back the
california refugees who fled the hell
hole he created an estate to florida
okay so here's the thing
about what he's doing we get it he's
running okay
and we get it
they think florida's running now here's
the thing desantis is running here's the
thing
if you're part of the lgbtq community
okay if you are where are you better off
florida or california
florida
what do you think i'm actually curious
zero clue i don't know i'm not part of
that community you were hanging out with
them that's why i know that you weren't
you weren't but you're like i don't make
my decisions based on what's good but
actually think about it i don't know
think about where are they gonna be
better off in florida or california well
let me ask a question a different way
where are you better off if you're
running a business florida or california
florida florida okay where are you
better if you can't stand we're in a
mask
florida
where are you better if you are part of
the lgbtq community i i would say
california because they're very it's
what is florida doing to actively
discriminate against lgbt exactly where
i'm nothing
you've seen the thing yeah don't say gay
right
now
the whole thing but by the way by the
way
when you poach
which is what he's doing and what
desantis is doing this is a poaching
game okay when you're poaching
who's desantis poaching
californians business owners correct
yeah come here open up yeah listen come
over here business owners who are
independent responsible you and me yeah
who is newsome trying to poach
people that the people that are just
leaving the state so
but i'm actually being very serious who
is he trying to poach
who's he so he's he's targeting lgbtq
community fine that's the community you
want to put what what other community so
do you think his argument for business
owners
leaving florida to california how many
business owners do you think will leave
florida to go to california after that
speech yeah let me think zero but i'm
being serious
how can you poach them is he gonna
approach guys that don't like high taxes
is he going to poach guys that are
willing to go out there and start a
business and you know is he going to
poach those guys he's not no so his
campaign
who you think is going to watch that and
be inspired to want to come to your
state he's recruiting victims none of
the people you want so guess what
descent is if you're recruiting victims
and if i am desantis and newsome says
this if newsom said that if i'm desantis
i say go go to california
my campaign would be very simple if you
like high taxes if you like a ton of
entitlement programs
if you like to be forced to take the
vaccine if you like to be forced to put
on damask if you want to i have a great
state for you to move to it's called uh
california if you like the worst
homelessness fyi fyi if i'm the the
leader of the republican party the
conservative party right now and i'm not
talking about like i'm talking about
strategists behind closed doors the
campaign people guess what i'm doing i'm
getting all the state governors together
and i'm saying guys what's the one state
you're never going to win and it doesn't
matter anyways california why don't you
send everybody a one-way greyhound
ticket straight to california let's fund
it you know what that does that locks in
your state okay
let's sell california is the state to
move if you're the following category
it's brilliant go forward
and you start driving it hey listen you
feel like that you should go to
california you should move to california
you should move to california you should
move to california you should go to
california yeah and then business
owner's gonna be like but if you're this
this this you should move to florida you
should move to tennessee you should move
to texas you should move through this
you know so i'm one of those people too
uh as i was reading that person that
just moved here from california
pat i'm sorry but
i'm going back you he sold me right
there you're really you're rescinding um
you're sending off your offer you know
what
take that offer you know where you can
go i'm going back because you know i
want the homelessness i want the taxes i
want because you know the second
pandemic is coming and trust me if you
want to be in a [ __ ] place that
stays to what you know vouching them say
i'm going back to florida and back to
cali so by the way i would love love
love love to see a new some desantis uh
presidential election i would love that
by the way i i would love to get the
biden trump situation yeah let's close
that chapter let's let some 40 and 50
year olds i love that and let the market
decide i love that let the market decide
who do you think be honest who do you
think i think that uh desantis would be
the favorite i think so too and i'd love
to see that let's get some new ideas get
some fresh ideas bring your california
bring your florida stuff and let let's
have a real intellectual debate you guys
should have seen that when i was in when
i was in cali when the nuke the new some
recall was going on i've never seen that
many people
out loud at the gas station and [ __ ]
like just pissed off they're just angry
they were just like we gotta get this
you know guy the hell out of there and i
think but larry elmo was like no they
still
by a landslide but people that were
scared to talk were coming out and just
openly saying like what the hell are
these but that again going back to my
point that is the most loyal party the
the the the laugh and cali
i would be i would i would do this i
would do a press conference and i would
say
governor newsom uh i'd like to uh at no
cost to your state at all
you don't need to pay me a salary i'm
not going to take money away from your
tax revenues that you're bringing in
don't worry about any of that stuff
consider me your chief recruiting
officer okay exactly strategy and here's
what i'd like to say and who are you who
are you saying this happens to know
something okay okay and if you if you if
you're the following and i'm gonna go
through it if you like this if you like
this i highly
highly recommend
you move to california highly recommend
it go there if you like these following
things um anyways i don't listen the
people in california like you know how
you're saying
you just said right now i was in a gas
station i was in this i was in that i
was in this i was like oh my god you
know everybody wanted this guy out not
really not in california they did not
okay the people that the core core
people that live in california don't
want this guy out the part when i said
on world star when biden put that up and
99 of all the people trashed him that's
america to me okay believe it or not to
me that's more america than what
california thinks because that to me is
not america
that's california california is like
france it's only yeah it's only yeah
it's it's our country you know there's a
game behind the game here to step back
from this to look at what newsom is
trying to do
here's a game where is the money for the
presidential elections is it in the
individual campaigns or is it a dnc it's
a dnc because when you win the primary
the dnc's got the big treasure chest and
they drive that hard but the dnc also
controls the green lighting system of
whether you're allowed to primary a
sitting president in your own party
right now they need the midterm election
to be done and it's going to be bad they
need q3 economic it's going to be bad
they need the q4 economic report and
it's probably gonna be bad with those
three items pat mark my words the dnc
will suddenly subtly
allow
formal primary activities against biden
right now the dnc will not permit it
they will not permit you to go up
against a sitting president what newsom
is doing is he's testing because he's
going to test this and they're going to
run all those phone calls if you've ever
taken a political phone call did you see
recently uh so-and-so said so and so
yeah how did you think about that how
did and they ask you they're going to be
testing this to see how this
campaign speech this stump speech that
he just did worked against desantis and
they're going to be making the case hey
listen we're the only viable candidate
kamala harris not her no we're the
viable candidate you need to be behind
us you need to allow the green lighting
process to happen you need to allow me
to start doing you know primary work in
earnest and when the dnc behind closed
doors subtly says
okay gavin you can um you can start
preparing primary bash against that's
when it will happen have you ever
noticed that all of a sudden you go from
speculative iowa candidates to suddenly
there would be
there would be actually validated iowa
candidates in both political parties
that's when the rnc dnc step up
and that's when they that's when the big
dollars start to come out now you have
to raise money as a campaign but there's
bigger dollars behind you and
newsom is campaigning
less against desantis right now pat but
he's campaigning against biden with the
dnc to be the guy they get behind if
they're going to primary a sitting
president got you you really think it's
newsom
you think newsome tom you think newsom
is the guy that's running a primary uh
unless michelle steps up i think he's
probably
gonna test the best i
i just i i think there's no way that
they don't get michelle in the race i
think i don't think they i legitimately
don't think with anybody on your page
i
don't think they're that stupid i think
they know they can't win with pete they
can't win with kamala they can't win
with gavin they can't win with andrew
cuomo they they can't win with anybody
well here's my question they keep
sending kamala out to mispronounce
foreign right and this is and i think
bill bilbert hit this a while ago when
he's like you know what the the what's
she has zero qualification technically
to become a president she was just the
wife of a president do you think people
will see past that and be like they know
that she's not running the show they're
gonna are they still gonna be able to
deal with these policies and everything
that the left has put in place just to
have a different face that makes them
feel good like oh my god they you know
they they put in a woman that of course
it's like it's come on got a high q
score people it's like by the way same
presidency when obama did that very iq
score five weeks ago obama did an event
at biden and biden was looking like the
neglected steps i saw him chasing him
yes as obama he did that like robotic
yeah he's like dad dad yeah and by the
way that will be the michelle presidency
she will have her moment but that's
going to be obama and the obama people
running the country 100 that's obviously
well that's no different to what it is
now of course it is
yeah
it'll be the same people running behind
the scenes it'll just be a better face
i think it'll be even i think there's
part of it that they're in part of it
that they're not but there'll be even
more of it if it's michelle well anyways
that's the stories for today we got a
bunch more that we didn't get into but
it was a great podcast
uh we covered a lot when is your next
show you got what it's thursday there's
thursday anything you're doing crazy we
got some special stuff going on we're
talking about how expensive food is
these days okay good and then uh vinnie
you got a video coming out yeah
valuetainment comedy i'm trying to post
on on fridays in the morning
uh we're going to release another sketch
this friday please subscribe guys
there's gonna be a lot of funny crazy
characters coming out i love it and then
uh tyler what do we got thursday
uh thursday we have thursday we're doing
podcasts or no yeah we're doing podcasts
we got jedediah wednesday and friday and
then thursday we have
today i don't see anything on the
calendar for thursday so i'm in town so
we're probably doing we're doing
something we're doing something on
thursday okay guys well have a great day
we'll see you guys on thursday bye bye
bye everybody bye guys
you